NEAL RICHARDSON: You
know that feeling you
get when you've got these
really, really good results,
and you're just really excited
to share them with the world
and you think everyone's going
to be really excited to see
what results you have?
And then you get
that other feeling
you sometimes get with that
one when you get this sinking
suspicion that maybe those
really good results are just
too good to be true.
So this happened to
me a few months ago.
I lead the engineering
team at Ursa Labs.
We're one of the leading
developers behind the Apache
Arrow project.
So Arrow, as you may
know, is essentially
building the foundation for the
next generation of data frames
and bigger data analysis.
And I maintain
arrow's R package.
So I was meeting with
RStudio's leadership
because RStudio has been a
generous sponsor of Ursa Labs
from the beginning.
So I'm in the call, and I'm
there with Hadley Wickham
and with JJ Allaire,
founder and CEO of RStudio,
Tareef Kawaf, who's president.
And I was talking
about this result
that I found recently, which was
I've been benchmarking Arrow's
CSV reader and found that
Arrow has lots of great things
that it does in its library.
I'm going to show you
some of them in this talk.
But even if you just use
arrow as a CSV reader
and use it to read
a data frame into R
and then you could use any other
R package on that data frame
afterwards, you can
get a big benefit.
And in fact, even, on this
particular New York City taxi
dataset that I was
testing out on,
I found that Arrow
was two to three times
faster than data.table's
CSV reader.
And at this point, Hadley
cuts me off and says,
yeah, I don't know.
That doesn't sound right.
I mean, data.table,
that group, they
have optimized really everything
that you could optimize out
of reading data into
R. And so maybe you
could match their performance,
maybe get a little bit better,
but you couldn't be that
much better because they've
done everything you could do.
And Tareef added, yeah, you
probably screwed up something
in your benchmarking code.
You know, you probably
actually didn't do all the work
you thought you did.
And I thought about
it, and it's like, wow,
that's actually a much more
logical, simpler explanation
for the result that I
found-- that I screwed up
something in my code.
But I figured I'd go check
it out and get back to them.
And I compared the
objects that I had.
The data frames read by
both were the same size--
15 million rows, both
really big in memory.
So it checked out.
It turned out Arrow's CSV
reader was two or three times
faster than data table's here.
So we'd achieved an
incredible result.
It was literally incredible.
Like, this group
of people here that
know a lot about
the internals of R
literally did not believe
that it was this fast.
So how are we able to do that?
So what I want to talk about
today is how characteristics
of the Arrow project and
particularly the community
around it enable us to do
things that we might otherwise
have thought would be
impossible to do in R.
So a little history--
so Arrow was started in 2016.
A group of database developers
and data frame library
maintainers got
together and realized
that they were all trying
to solve similar problems.
And then rather than saying,
you know, this is fine
and we're just going
to keep duplicating
each other's work, what
if we work together
and create a shared
foundation for our work,
and we would all
benefit from that?
So Arrow is fundamentally
about three things.
First, it is a format.
It is a specification for how
data is represented in memory.
It's columnar, and
it's designed to take
advantage of features
of modern CPUs
and GPUs and other hardware.
There's also a set of 12
libraries that implement it
in different languages.
Python and R use
the C++ library,
but there are many others
in the Arrow project.
And then third, there's
this broader ecosystem
of packages and
projects around Arrow,
that use Arrow in some
form, whether it's
as their internal data
model or as it's just
a means of exchange
between projects.
So how do these
characteristics of arrow
lead us to get such
unbelievable performance
and be able to enable us
to do things that we didn't
think were possible in R?
So in terms of modern
hardware, arrow
is designed to take advantage
of many features of CPUs
that exist now that didn't exist
when R was developed initially.
So R was first released in 1995.
Of course, computer technology
has progressed quite a bit
since then.
And there are things that
I can do on my laptop now
that was not something
that was a thing back then.
So for example, my laptop
here's got eight course.
That's CPUs that you
can run in parallel.
You can get a host
on AWS with 96 cores.
That's pretty good.
But R is generally only
using one of those.
So we're leaving a lot of
performance on the table.
Newer CPUs also
can take advantage
of what's called SIMD--
Single Instruction,
Multiple Data.
My laptop, for example, can
take up to 256 bits at a time.
So that would be the size
of eight integers in R.
Other newer ones
can do 512 bits.
So you can feed a lot
more data into the CPU
at a time if your
code is designed
to take advantage of that.
But R generally is not.
So it's like you have this
super fast sports car,
and you just want to take it
for a spin around the track
and see what you can do with it.
But for whatever
reason, you have
to keep it under
25 miles an hour,
drive, keep your hands
at 10:00 and 2:00
on the handle on
the steering wheel--
nothing too crazy.
And it's a really
missed opportunity.
So what do you do about that?
So you could write some C or
C++ code in your R package to do
multi-threading to take
advantage of all those extra
cores that you have available.
You could write code to
do some de-optimizations.
But that's really hard,
frankly, and the number
of people that
know how to do that
well isn't that great probably.
And the number of people
who do that and are
going to be writing R
packages is even smaller.
So here's where the large Arrow
community comes in hand it
here.
So the Arrow project has had,
since it was created in 2016,
has had a steady
growth of contributors
to the project over time,
well over 500 by now.
And what this means
is all of these people
are working together
on this project that--
and the benefits are shared.
So in order to have smart
multi-threading in the R
package, I didn't
have to write that.
Someone else who understands how
to do that much better than I
would did that.
I didn't have to write
SIMD code either.
There are other
people, people who
work on hardware, that's
the actual CPUs themselves,
that know what
those options are.
They wrote that code.
And they're all
contributing it in.
And they're not all
contributing it in
because they want to make
the R package faster.
They're contributing because
they are using the C++ library
for some other project,
or they're using Python,
which uses the same C++
library that the R package does.
So we benefit from all of
these other communities'
contributions.
So what does that look like?
So to give an example of how
this work plays out in reality,
I want to talk
about this example
this demo that I gave last
year at RStudio conference.
I was introducing
the Arrow R package,
and I was going
through this example
with the data set where you take
about 10 and 1/2 years of New
York City taxi data,
2 billion rows,
and you could scan that and
to get some results on that
on your laptop.
So I did some kind
of sample dplyr,
filtering and selecting and
grouping and aggregating
on this dataset that I
opened with the error package
where I planted a
directory of these files,
and then I could query it.
And I got a result
in four seconds--
over 2 billion rows.
And that was pretty good--
really happy with that.
I did a talk this past summer,
and I redid the result just
on the latest
version of the code.
And it was twice as fast.
And I hadn't really done
anything in the R package
to do that.
This is all based on
improvements in the underlying
C++ code that all the rest of
the community was working on.
Right before I
did this talk now,
I ran the code again
on the latest version,
and it's another 25% faster.
Again, I didn't do anything
to make that happen.
It's just based on the Arrow
community and its work.
So you know, there's
other reasons,
other ways that this ecosystem
plays out and has benefits
for us in the R community.
So when you hear that a
bunch of database developers
got together and decided
that there wasn't
a good standard
for columnar data
and they were going to create
their own standard to unify all
of these, it might
bring this "XKCD" comic
to mind where the
creation of standards
to solve the lack
of standards just
makes more problems,
more competing standards.
And there certainly
is that risk.
But five years on from
the creation of Arrow,
we can see now how the
benefits of this approach
have played out.
So just to give an example, so
suppose I've got data in Spark,
and I want really quick access
to that in Python and R.
What you could do is that you
could, from Spark, you could
write a special adapter for
Python, a special adapter
for R, that understands--
in R's case, it understands
R's vector types
and specific-- the
bits in the vectors
that make up a data frame.
And you have to do the same
thing for Python, for NumPi,
or Pandas.
And Spark and its
Java code would have
to understand how to do this.
I put another Arrow
in the chart there
to connect the interchange
between Python and R.
That's obviously something
you'd want to do too,
and it's another place
where you'd need someone
on the other side of
the language barrier
to understand the
internals of your format.
So that's feasible if this
is all you care about,
but in reality, there's
many more languages,
and there's many more
projects and too many
to fit on the slide.
And as you can imagine, if you
try to draw all of those lines
to connect the various adapters
to the the different things,
it gets crazy really quickly.
So what do you do?
You're obviously not
going to do that.
That's too much work.
And so what you want is to
have a ubiquitous standard
that everyone can
write to and read from.
And then you don't have
to implement everything
every time.
So prior to Arrow, what you do
is you probably just dump out
a CSV.
Every language knows
how to read a CSV.
Every database knows
how to read in a CSV.
But this comes with some costs.
CSVs can be expensive
to read and write
because you have to convert
between a string format on disk
to the arrays of bits
that R and other languages
use in memory to do work.
And that conversion is costly.
And CSV also doesn't have
rich support for types.
You know, you may
have time stamps,
and you don't have
any way of indicating
that this is a timestamp.
You have to guess whether it
should be just a regular string
or a time stamp.
And so there's lots
of costs and penalties
that come from doing this.
But CSV is kind of the
lowest common denominator.
And so that's why
it gets picked up.
But Arrow is kind
of a happier version
of that where you have a
standard, and it's columnar,
and it's binary.
So it matches very closely
with how R or Julia or Spark
or any of these
languages actually
work with data and memory.
So the conversion is
minimal and in some cases
doesn't actually
involve copying memory
because where it
does actually line up
as being the same shape.
So it's very efficient.
And from our perspective
in the R community,
what this means
is once we have--
and now that we have
an Arrow R package,
we have access to all of these
other projects and databases
and languages very efficiently
as long as they also
can write to Arrow.
And over the last
five years, we've
seen an increasing
number of projects
that have picked up
on Arrow for this
because it's really efficient.
So going back to Spark
for our example there,
early on in Arrow's
life, we added support
in PySpark, the
Python Spark library,
to communicate with
Spark, the database,
which is written in Java,
very efficiently using Arrow.
And so you'd get 100-fold
speed up on certain operations,
whether it's with
user defined functions
or whether you're just
pulling a large amount of data
into your Python environment
to do further analysis on it.
And that worked because
Java has an Arrow library,
Python has an arrow library,
and they write the same format.
The beauty of this is
that once we finally
got the R package
going, we could
pick up and do the same thing.
These are both
references to blog posts
on the Arrow website.
So we were able to take
advantage of the same thing.
And because we can read
and write Arrow from R,
we didn't need to do any other
special Spark business in order
to get those 100x speed
ups of pulling data
to and from Spark in R.
So the Arrow format is
designed to take advantage
of modern hardware,
and the power
of the large community of
developers around the Arrow
project really changed
what we're able to do in R
and enable all sorts
of new workflows
that weren't really
possible or feasible before.
So you know, it's nice, like
I showed in the beginning,
to see that arrow makes, like,
reading CSVs into R faster,
and we like seeing that.
But that's really not the goal.
We're not just trying to
shave off a little bit of time
from work that you
already can do now.
We're trying to go beyond that.
We're trying to enable
new workflows that we're
either cost prohibitive
to do before or just
frankly not possible at all.
So there's a lot more coming in
the coming releases this year
in 2021.
We're really excited to be
able to tell you about them
when they come.
But for now, I wanted to
just go back and walk you
through another example of
something you can do today
in the Arrow package that is
a little bit beyond what you
would normally do
in R but can really
have some impossible
seeming results, let's say.
So earlier, I showed reading
a dataset of 125 files of New
York City taxi data.
It was in the Parquet format.
Parquet is a file
format that you
can read in the Arrow package.
It's a columnar, very
efficient file format.
Often, of course, you don't
have Parquet files yet,
and one of the reasons
you want to use Arrow
is to get your less efficient
CSV data into Parquet
so that you can read
it more quickly.
So the Arrow package has some
facilities for doing this.
So here's an example.
I converted some of those
Parquet files back to CVS.
I only did six months of
it because CSVs are big,
and it takes a lot of space.
But just as you can point in
the directory of Parquet files
and say, open dataset,
you can do that with CSVs.
And you can do the same
kinds of queries on them
that I showed with
the Parquet dataset--
selecting and filtering,
grouping, aggregating,
all of these things.
As you see, the
result here, the one I
showed-- it was a
different query.
So it's not apples to apples,
but it took 7 and 1/2 seconds
to do this query over this data.
It's pretty good.
The fact I didn't have to mess
with reading each of the files
individually and doing
things with it, that's good.
But I think we can do better.
So one of the
things we want to do
is we could write the data set
to a more efficient format,
either Parquet, as I
mentioned, or Feather,
which is the Arrow format.
It's literally the
Arrow format on disk.
So we can use similar types of
dplyr style syntax to do this.
I can say group by this payment
type column in the dataset.
That was one of the columns
that I filtered on before.
And in this case, when I'm
writing a dataset, when
I say group_by,
what that means is
I want you to partition
my data by that.
And what that's
going to do is it's
going to write
out separate files
inside different
directories based
on the value of that variable.
So payment type in this dataset
took on values one to five.
So now I've got, inside
my feather taxi directory,
I've got five
subdirectories, one
for each of the
values of payment type
that now have different
Parquet files or feather files,
excuse me.
And what this means
is when I do a query
again on this dataset, I only--
and if I filter on
payment type, I only
have to look at the files
inside that directory that
correspond to the
value of payment type
that I'm filtering on.
I don't even have to
read the other files in
to see if they match
my filter because I've
kind of pre-filtered it
based on this partitioning.
So indeed, if we do the
same query that I just
did on the CSVs but I
do it on the feather
version of the dataset,
it's now 100 times faster
than before-- exact same query
just with a more efficient file
format and taking
advantage of partitioning
in the dataset query.
So this is great.
We're trying to make things
that have been difficult
or impossible possible,
trying to help
you take full advantage
of the sports car
that you've got on your lap
when you're working in R.
But you know, I
really like to think
what we have is not
just any old sports car,
but it's a DeLorean perhaps
with a flux capacitor in it.
And where we're going,
we don't need roads.
We're going beyond
what you could be doing
on your laptop today even.
So thank you very much.